you'd think after an ending like that
the MCU would take some time to breathe
before announcing 7,000 new projects but
you can't stop the Money Train now so
over the course of this year San Diego
comic-con and d23 Kevin and company
announced about 7,000 new projects some
sound really awesome and intriguing and
others are a show about Loki Oh God even
though nobody asked me let's go down the
list and talk about all the things in
the MCU over the next few years and
maybe touch a little bit on what what
won't be there either
whitewash Widow it's kind of cool that
she's finally getting your own movie
after so long I can't tell if everyone
hates Scarlett Johansson or not still
but it has a Marvel logo on it so it'll
make a billion dollars regardless this
time our favorite tree will be up
against all kinds of super spy espionage
stuff in post-civil war pre infinity war
Marvel World so many wars I think
setting it in this timespan is a little
strange and limiting because it doesn't
give her the opportunity to hang out
with Hawkeye really and the whole movie
will really feel weird knowing the
characters ultimate fate I think I would
have preferred to put her trilogy
somewhere in the post Thanos kills
everyone era because that's five years
in a really dreary crazy world where
society would be insane though there's
always room to put the sequels in there
if they decide to give her a posthumous
movie trilogy Captain Falcon and Big
Boss so this is one of the shows I'm
looking forward to the most because I
like that they're finally giving us a
little more to work with from Baron Zemo
I like him a lot as a villain but I was
disappointed with how little they did
with him so it's gonna be cool to see
him more developed across a longer
format and finally where is cheesy ass
costume we've all been waiting for if
you're writing a comment going speak for
yourself it's costume is stupid you're
uninvited my birthday party [ __ ]
otherwise I hope both of these nerds
take turns throwing the shield at stuff
and maybe using it to crack nuts and
prop up short table legs maybe they'll
surprise us with that old man Steve
cameo and he'll show up to talk about
all the awkward conversations he had for
the past 30 years explaining to Peggy
why he can't look their little blonde
niece in the eye oh look they're already
halfway there also I guess everyone just
forgot buck he's a war criminal so
that's nice good for him what do I say
that's funny about Shang Chi's name
that's not like racist I was really
hoping this guy would turn up an iron
fist but I guess having typhoid mary a
daredevil villain seemed more prude
I personally don't know much about the
character outside the fact that he's
basically Bruce Lee his dad is
fu-manchu's I'm not joking look that up
he doesn't really have powers but then
one day he can do that thing multiple
man does and a lot of annoying people
are going to come out of the woodwork
saying they're closeted shang-chi
superfans for clout in the months
leading up to the movie despite only
really vaguely remembering him in that
one ultimate spider-man arc being a
character typically shown to not have
powers I hope they really build up the
fantasy elements in this one to justify
it not being a TV show or something
smaller in scope judging by the fact
that they'll finally have the real
Mandarin show up and tie up that stupid
loose end from a billion years ago I
think we can assume that's a case he'll
at this point we've seen enough weird
[ __ ] in these movies I think they can
get away with shang-chi fist fighting
Fin Fang Foom why not
eternal moles I know about as much about
these characters as anyone else and I'm
not going to pretend I have a lot to say
about them in spite of that I hope it's
cool I don't mind Marvel taking obscure
cosmic characters and giving them the
spotlight because they have a pretty
good track record with that all I know
is Jack Kirby definitely designed better
costumes than this ish ColecoVision for
some reason all MCU stands on twitter
arbitrarily decided they ate these
characters or they hate everyone except
these characters but I personally don't
mind them as much I think it would be
cool if they took some inspiration from
Tom King's vision comic where the goofy
red Android is trying to be a suburban
dad and live a normal life although they
still gotta figure out how to undo this
things that might take up most of the
running time stranger things in the
mouth of madman I find myself in an
extreme minority opinion here but I
think my least favorite MCU film is
Doctor Strange the visuals are stunning
but I find the characters the story the
villain and a lot of the world building
to be pretty lackluster
I especially couldn't get over the
awkward comedy bits that were clearly
added and reshoots because the test
audiences felt the movie was too serious
because they feel out of place and hold
the film back from having more emotional
weight but being said Doctor Strange was
great in Ragnarok and infinity war when
he got to interact with better written
characters and fight a villain that
didn't suck so maybe there's some hope
for this one yet if they just boost
everything else
kick-ass trippy visuals alone a good
movie do not make
they're marketing this whole thing with
like a horror aspect to it and I've gone
on record before saying I'm very
interested in the idea of a horror
themed superhero movie Fantastic Four
dabbled in that a little bit before
getting muddled into just a bunch of
generic we can do a team action scenes
venom dropped the ball on that super
hard when the messy pg-13 cut was put
together at the last second open the
door for a spider-man crossover and New
Mutants has been banished to the Shadow
Realm
I just think the MCU won't take the risk
they're promising with that maybe one or
two scenes will show some scary or dark
imagery while the rest of it is just a
bunch of this try me Beyonce I'd love to
be proven wrong though especially since
the director has a background in horror
movies also Wanda will be there too for
some reason she's the only other
character who waves her hands around in
a weird way that makes things explode
Loki should have stayed dead also
apparently he was under mind control
when he committed that teensy little
genocide all terrorists attack so it's
not really his fault you guy is he's
still a precious cinnamon bun who
deserves the whole world and also to be
railed by Thor [ __ ] hate Twitter
speaking of stands everyone seems to
hate Hawkeye because he's not deaf and
or training Kate bishop and or isn't a
depressed hipster millennial dad that
drinks coffee and has bandages on his
face apparently a lot of people seem to
forget that this character did in fact
exist before the Matt Fraction comic but
I guess that doesn't matter now and
we'll never see him wear this costume
unless it's a flashback that lasts for
30 seconds or scene where he tries it on
in the mirror and then says you this
sucks
because that joke never gets old ever
hopefully they'll have Clint write a
heartfelt apology to the families of
those Yakuza and cartel members he
killed because he's raised as what if I
were to purchase fast food and disguises
as my own this show sounds really cool
conceptually I like the idea of doing a
weird else world version of each movie
in the MCU thus far and it's even more
impressive that they have a lot of the
movie cast doing the voices over 7,000
percent of the show's budget will go to
having Robert Downey jr. saying about
four lines of dialogue but it'll be
worth it
Thor Sex in the City I guess it's kind
of interesting that they'll be giving
Jane Foster something to do
this time i know natalie portman wasn't
exactly the biggest fan of the movies
she was in already but when they say you
get to be the title character of a
Marvel movie and we'll roll up to your
house with a dump truck full of money
it's hard to turn down I just worry
because the Jason Aaron run on Thor was
based around Jane Foster being a pretty
different character I don't know how
they'll adapt certain story elements of
it to fit the MCU version her having
cancer might be too depressing so
they'll just say she has light back
problems that make it hard to carry too
many groceries all at once which will be
cured by the use of Mjolnir however the
hell they managed to get that back again
if you ever needed any further evidence
that the Marvel Netflix shows were not
really canon and none of the higher-ups
cared about them at all just look at
cottonmouth taking on the role of blade
don't get me wrong
this is [ __ ] wonderful casting and
he's gonna kick ass but it's a little
disheartening to see that they just
really can't even attempt to keep up the
illusion anymore well it's all conducted
it's nice though because Mahalo got
jacked pretty hard in Luke Cage it was a
great idea to set up this awesome
villain and then unceremoniously kill
him off halfway through the season
really subverted my expectations there
what a waste of talent
I know some folks are pissed that it's
not Wesley Snipes again but a he's
getting a little bit too old for the
role now and pulling off such a
physically demanding character is harder
than it was 20 years ago
the man's almost 60 now B it would very
much complicate the MCU can and to use
him because that would imply his trilogy
is canon and we have to explain why no
one's talked about how interwoven
vampires are into society before and see
he's notoriously hard to work with just
look at all that stuff that went on
behind the scenes of Trinity like how he
refused to open his eyes for one shot so
they just had to fix it in post if you
call that fixing it
give my Herschel Ollie a chance I think
he can really bring something special to
this eye it's gonna be pg-13 as [ __ ]
Jesus they just will not let up on the
Disney Plus shows will they they really
want you to pay for another streaming
service as if the seven or eight you
have already aren't starting to really
add up and break the bank I remember the
good old days when everything was just
kind of split up evenly between the two
and
maybe there was a third option if you're
a hipster contrarian like David now you
got to pay 10 to 20 dollars each just so
you can watch like two things on each
service I'm sick of this [ __ ] can we
just not this is worse than paying for
cable channels we've progressed whatever
you don't care
miss Marvel it's gonna be pretty cool to
see a high school oriented superhero
with a secret identity the MCU since
we're lacking one of those these days
huh oh oh my god this videos getting too
tiresome there Scott will you take over
for me while I take a nap she-hulk
okay here's my pitch for how to make
this show super radical awesome make
sure to keep the courtroom stuff that
Jennifer Walters is known for because
she's a lawyer there's a bit of a void
left behind now that our other courtroom
drama superhero show is gone but not
forgotten next
maybe dabble in some of that fourth wall
breaking comedy that she-hulk used to be
known for but never go to overboard with
it that it becomes excessive just little
subtle nods and cracks about it here and
there to make her funny but in a unique
way from every other funny Marvel
protagonist in these shows and movies
have Marky Mark buffalo sauce show up
every now and then to develop their
cousin dynamic you don't have to have
him Hulk out just be there as a
supporting character and influence her
origin story heck you can set it in that
weird five year gap and have him
discover how to become Professor Hulk in
the show now the part I can't emphasize
enough get Tim Roth to be the villain of
the show really make him menacing and
take a little longer to develop his
character Emil Blonsky had
super-strength that made him a match for
the Hulk in his human form so he can
still do action scenes with him without
breaking the budget turning him into
abomination every time then set that up
to be the big thing in the conclusion of
the first season and really hype up him
transforming into a big monster again
maybe even make him bigger and scarier
than before and if you still got time
after all that you can even tie up that
loose end with Samuel Sterns what's that
guy been up to for the past 10 years
they will do none of this he'll Jen will
probably be a scientist or something and
get beamed with gamma rays on accident
never interact with
they'll make like two jokes about her
becoming a lawyer but never actually do
it the villain will be the mercy I guess
because they haven't used her in
anything yet and you don't have to spend
a lot of money on it her costume is just
a purple robe moon night he's probably
gonna make me really sad after seeing
how Deadpool and Punisher have been
treated lately I can tell you the show
will probably be decent but fail to
capture the characters core essence this
is one of the darkest comics in Marvel
and I can already tell they're going to
water it down and make loony Mooney more
marketable to a big audience just like
how they leaned more into comedy
elements for Deadpool and only barely
touched on the heavier stuff or how they
made Punisher a reluctant Jason Bourne
Wolverine hybrid that has to convince
himself to punish constantly that's a
lot more likeable than a deranged serial
killer on a lifelong mission to
eradicate a huge chunk of the human
population I did a whole video about
this go watch it
so anyway moon night kicks people so
hard they vomit he carves a moon logo
into people's foreheads he crashed a
helicopter and a taskmaster because he
was too lazy to fight him hand-to-hand
and he once kept a human face is a
souvenir after violently killing his
nemesis by tackling him off a rooftop
and stabbing him repeatedly then he
would sometimes put the face on and look
in the mirror while hearing the voices
in his head tell him to sacrifice more
souls to a frightening elder god that
looks like a bird skeleton then his
girlfriend walked in on that and it led
to an awkward dinner that night you see
what I'm getting at here you think
they're gonna put a character like that
on something with Disney in the name no
they'll just make him Batman and white
because that's easier to market I bet
they'll only keep spectres
disassociative identity disorder as a
traumatic thing from his past that he's
already gotten over by the time the show
starts because mental illness isn't sexy
or something a few years ago I would
have been ecstatic for this announcement
but now I just can't help but feel
worried they're going to misrepresent
this character and it'll have a negative
effect on his comics Moon Knight comics
are great because the character is so
obscure a niche that the writers can do
whatever abstract or dark things they
want and have a lot of creative freedom
the more mainstream the character gets
the less they'll be able to do with him
is they won't want to scare away the big
influx of
new readers picking up the books after
the show so we won't get risky stuff
like the spiritual a haunting detective
based 2014 run or the mind-bending
character study acid trip of the 2016
comic or the ultra violent political
drama of the 2006 run they'll make the
comics more safe and accessible just
like the show will be this is how we get
things like the Scottie Young Deadpool
book if you've read it you know what I'm
talking about they were to do it right
it would be darker and more artsy
something kind of like what they did
with Legion but I wouldn't hold my
breath
sure I sound like a pessimist but I'll
reiterate my earlier point I would love
to be proven wrong now on to the future
of spider-man if there is one I kind of
not sure if I want to speculate on this
one that's why you should watch my video
speculate again live a boy baby hey
Scott save that for the end
oh [ __ ] I feel like we'll get a
definitive answer in a few days and make
this video feel pretty instantly dated
but I think there's a few ways this can
shake out one Disney and Sony come to
some deal and then continue with
business as usual following through with
their plan to have spider-man be the
heart of the MCU going forward and get
older as the series progresses becoming
a more traditional spider-man like the
one in the comics currently a little
while ago they were talking about how
Tom had like nine more movies in his
contract before everything fell through
to Sony just runs off with him and makes
a conclusion to Tom Spidey's trilogy so
we can find out what the hell they were
doing with that post-credit scene I
walked out of the theater that day
joking with my friend that it felt like
the kind of post-credits scene you get
when the series is about to be cancelled
or rebooted so something like the
sinister six setup or the Deathstroke
appearance or a Baraka pool this would
be kind of weird because then this
trilogy would wrap up with spider Morty
over here no longer acknowledging any of
the other MCU stuff of which his
character is written entirely around
like happy Hogan and Avengers and Iron
Man and [ __ ] where he even got his
suit all can't really be touched on
anymore it's not impossible to pull off
it would just be a lot harder
hopefully the spider-man homes
last trilogy gets a conclusion either
way cuz it sucks that every spiderman
thing keeps getting cancelled early
option 3 sony just says [ __ ] it and
makes a new spider-man from scratch for
the 40th time and he's in his mid-20s in
dating a white redhead MJ and has been
spider-man for a few years now and it
takes place in the same universe as
venom it would look something like the
ps4 game in terms of characterization
for somehow they haggle their way into
doing option 1 again but then venom is
also there and that's now canon to the
MCU 5 reboot with miles I guess I'm
nervous about this one for a few reasons
the main one being that spider-verse is
already a perfect origin movie for him
and they'll never top it then there's
also how they'll have to dodge around a
lot of story elements for miles being
used for spider Tom and how it'll feel
kind of say me now there's also this
obnoxious phenomenon in fan communities
where they hate whatever came before and
automatically love and praise the
current thing just because it's the
current thing so we get a lot of people
shouting that Peter Parker is now a
terrible and outdated character and
miles should be the new main spider-man
and everything including the comics that
those people wouldn't read either way
because no one cares about comics do you
think I'm exaggerating but look how much
love Tobey got until he stopped being
current and then how much Pyle both him
and Andrew got as soon as Tom stepped in
as soon as they cast a new spider-man
all bets are off and whatever came
before is suddenly trash no matter how
much people loved it at one point
fandoms are fickle and stupid like this
and I for one am NOT looking forward to
more discourse about what spider-man is
the best one it's so tired but hopefully
if this is the route they go for it's
justified by miles as live-action debut
being pretty damn good because that
character deserves some love too I just
hate that people can't express their
appreciation for something without also
having to trash something else in the
same breath yeah ok mr. wiseguy in the
comments writing about 15 examples of me
doing that same thing you're so clever I
have made peace with the fact that all
of these are a possibility I've learned
to not get as attached to any one
interpretation of these
characters anymore I'm willing to accept
that they're going to be making
big-budget movies with Spidey forever
and it's unreasonable to stamp your foot
down and say no one can ever portray
your hero's ever again because someone
already nailed it
there will be another Tony Stark in a
movie someday and there will be a new
Wolverine sooner than you might think I
just hope that both are good in their
own right if Tom spoderman gets another
shot at finishing up his story in one
way or another that's great but if we
have to see someone else take on the old
webslinger that's fine too whatever
happens I just know I still love
spider-man thanks for indulging a few of
my side rambles here and there but
there's a lot I had to say and doing
this video is the best way to say all of
it once as much cynicism and sarcasm as
I throw at the MCU I still look forward
to all of this stuff and I want my more
sour predictions to be woefully
incorrect because I just want the best
for these stories and characters I think
the future is shaky right now for the
franchise because we're in a
transitional period between the old and
new they're still trying to discern
what's going to work and what won't
moving forward but I think there's a
chance they'll figure it out and wring
every last possible scent out of the
concept before general audiences become
bored by the 15 movies they need to see
every summer to understand the plot of
the next 15 movies coming out the
following year that ending was meant to
be a lot more sentimental but I couldn't
think of anything nice to say whoops
anyway don't be as grouchy as me and try
to keep a positive outlook some of this
stuff will be pretty damn cool and also
low-key if you like my editing on my
cameo in this video baby you should
watch my videos I made a video on film
and it was pretty [ __ ] good but no
one watched it so yeah watch it it's
good and
[Music]
also watch my you're not gonna watch it
yo [ __ ] Godzilla Mendoza fans you're
not going to watch my video about film
spider-man video as well please check
out my channel mine just dying you make
one video whenever for longer and
suddenly or amongst just a quick
reminder before you go that I post my
videos a day early on patreon and give
exclusive behind-the-scenes content and
patron exclusive videos please consider
becoming a patron it really helps me out
if you want a more short-term way to
support the channel you can check out my
merch and the links in the description
we have t-shirts phone cases posters
mugs pillows baby onesies and so much
more see you next time
[Music]
[Music]